it is friday morning and time for what's
trending las vegas now host mercedes
martinez
joining us live at the mix 94.1 studio
hey mercedes it's great to see you
i want to start with some sweetness you
too happy friday
uh and it is national cookie day too on
top of it so what's going on here
well this is pretty cool because keebler
is giving away
50 weeks worth of free cookies
to 50 people check this out so they're
calling it the keebler 50 and 50
challenge and
they want you to stack 50 of their fudge
stripes cookies in just 50 seconds and
post it on tick tock now
you don't actually have to do the
challenge to win you just have to go to
keebler's tick tock and drop an emoji
in the comments on their challenge video
um the contest
runs through tuesday by the way this
all coincides with the 50th anniversary
of ernie
the elf do you remember him he's so cute
he's being
been the keebler mascot for 50 years
it's so hard to believe
i know it and those cookies are so good
mercedes they are dangerous
if i stack 50 of those i i think i
probably only get to like 30. i'd have
to start taking bites as i go through it
i know it you know who else is trending
today is one of my favorites
posty post malone he
is doing it again he is billboard's top
artist of the year for the second year
in a row
now the top artists behind postie are
the weeknd
roddy rich the baby and drake so
you know i know a certain eight news now
anchor
loves drake but i don't i heard
it was you i'm not sure oh did you hear
rumblings yes
i love drake mercedes it is no secret
so speaking of love some fans are
convinced that taylor swift
could be engaged and mercedes you know
taylor swift fans notice everything
they are so observant see she is
re-recording
her music catalog now this past
week she re-recorded the song love story
and that song was in this match.com
commercial that you're seeing right now
it's a romance
between satan and the year 2020. so fans
noticed that instead
of saying the lyric baby just say
yes in this new re-record taylor now
sings
baby just said yes take a listen
[Music]
very observant and some fans are
speculating that she is re-releasing
love story of
all of her songs because of the
engagement so i guess we're just going
to have to wait and see him on this one
alex oh
how exciting uh have you seen that
commercial in full too
it's so interesting but it is a match
commercial so for her to change the
lyric you know it makes sense
it does it does and that that commercial
is hilarious satan in 2020 and they're
like i don't want the year to end and i
think all of us are like
please end yes now 26 more days
let's go mercedes it is so great to see
you
thank you so much for joining us and
have a good morning on your show